okay let's go back to our top story the
fighting in solidar in eastern Ukraine
we're going to speak to Charles
Stratford who's live outside the city of
bakmut in the donbass region so more
fighting in a part of the country which
is strategically important Charlie
what's been happening
will you join us Rob we're about five
kilometers outside of Bahamut solidar is
around 10 kilometers in that direction
I'm not sure whether you're going to be
able to pick this audio up but there's a
lot of heavy shelling going on all
around this area we've in the last few
minutes as well heard heavy machine gun
fire there's a checkpoint very close to
us as well we were prevented from going
any further towards Buck moot at that
checkpoint it seems as if they're only
allowing the military through
I was here what two and a half three
months ago and it's fair to say that the
situation has dramatically changed since
then I mean we used to go down this road
and into back moot then it is a lot
louder a lot more heavy shelling than
then we've actually been speaking to
soldiers this morning who've been inside
bakmud and asking them about the
situation in bakmut and solidar they
said to us that Russian forces were in
the center of solidar they said that
they were in control of that salt mine
they described Russian tanks in the
center of solidar as well they said that
they were concerns probably hear those
studs there there are concerns among the
Ukrainian forces about possible Escape
Routes for the Ukrainian forces inside
solidar he said what they were trying to
do was protect a western route out of
the Town we've been speaking to some of
the soldiers behind us here I'm sure
this in this vehicle these people have
been getting ready to evacuate soldiers
out of bakmut they say that there are
still a lot of civilians inside Bachman
we asked how many civilians there were
inside solidar he estimated around 500
civilians still inside solidar as the
fighting goes on and what's interesting
of course the big question is why has
this happened seemingly so suddenly this
big push towards solidar well the
soldiers that we spoke to said and with
respect to bakmut this intensification
of fighting he said it was literally
because the sheer numbers of Russian
forces like the recent weeks have been
amassing on the areas north of solidar
and various areas around bahut he said
that there were Russian forces fighting
inside the city of bahmoud he was
hesitant to give us exactly where that
front line was for security reasons but
there is a river that runs right the way
through bakmut and he said that the
Russian forces had not crossed that
River but as I say the situation here
incredibly tense and it was only I
suppose about sort of 10 15 minutes ago
where we saw what we believe was an air
defense system firing missiles of what
we understand saying were were Russian
missiles or potentially Russian aircraft
down towards Constantin ivica now that
town I suppose is about 10 kilometers in
that direction so yeah one can only
imagine the horrific situation for
civilians
trapped inside bakmut or refusing to
leave buckmut and those 500 or so that
we've been told are still in solidar
Charles Stratford talking to us outside
the city of bakmut in donbass Charles
thank you very much
or Wagner mercenaries I mean at the
Forefront of the battle in this part of
eastern Ukraine it takes a closer look
at the group and its role in the war
it's a small mining town but one that
could represent the first military
breakthrough for Russia in months
but at the Forefront of the battle is
the Wagner group a private military army
finance and equipped by the Russian
government
its leader is yevgeni pregojin a former
convict and close Ally of President
Vladimir Putin he was recently seen in
the salt mines of Soledad
well uh this is Eugenie burgosian
Flagship military Mission it's in back
boot and solidar and Eugenie pagosian is
locked currently in a shadow war against
the Russian defense minister as telegram
channels are discrediting Sergey shoigu
he's also clashing with regional
Governors like the St Petersburg
Governor Alexander beglov and he's
rumored to have political aspirations of
his own private military armies are
unconstitutional in Russia but the
Wagner group has grown to become an
informal and unofficial unit of the
regular Russian army the Wagner group
first appeared during the annexation of
Crimea in 2014. in 2015 about 300
Fighters were sent to the donbas to
support the russian-backed separatists
the group has also operated in places
like Syria Central African Republic
Libya and Mali among others initially
about 300 Wagner contractors took part
in the invasion of Ukraine in February
2022.
their mission according to Ukraine and
Western officials capture and kill
President Vladimir zielinski by March
their presence had tripled to one
thousand
and the Pentagon currently estimates
that at least 50 000 Fighters operating
in eastern Ukraine of which only ten
thousand are contractors the remaining
40 000 are convicts
Russia initially called The Invasion a
special military operation that would
quickly achieve the kremlin's goals but
it's told and Russia had to rethink its
military strategy that's when the role
of this private Army became more
prominent in eastern Ukraine with the
support of the regular army
they usually have some kind of uh
division of responsibility Uh Russian
regular army usually control
rocket missiles and Aviation and uh this
Wagner group
used a special
units of soldiers and officers for the
storming of some of the uh defense point
of Ukrainian Army
the group also enjoys a legal loophole
which allows its mercenaries to operate
more freely
they are glorified in a recently
released movie funded by the group
called the best in hell even though the
Wagner group has been accused of Human
Rights abuses in several countries it
operates in
if Soledad Falls it will pave the way
for the Russian army to head south
towards bakmut and West towards
kramatorsk it will also likely increase
the popularity of the Wagner group among
Russians further blurring the lines
between the private and regular armies
Al Jazeera